i want to end this show tonight on a
strong note and by strong we mean
rippling steroid-enhanced heavily tanned
biceps
cnn's chief bodybuilding correspondent
chris cuomo spent his sunday as he does
most weekends
hanging with strangers on social media
exchanging non-sequiturs with the vast
disproportionately mentally ill digital
throngs online
a group that for chris cuomo and so many
others in journalism fills the void
where actual loved ones
should be my twitter friends cuomo was
talking about himself as
always when a fellow twitter user
essentially told him to be quiet
you're going to break your arm he said
if you keep committing the crime for
which god smote down onan though we put
it more
colloquially than that we won't repeat
it how did chris combo respond to this
he didn't seem embarrassed you would
have been he wasn't
instead he sent a picture of that very
arm
is that how this happened cuomo wrote
come on baby
don't hate facilitate facilitate
what does that mean we're not sure but
it sounds like a pickup line we do know
that when chris cuomo asks you to
facilitate him
online it's time to turn off the ipad
and get back to dinner with the family
nothing good can happen next we hope his
twitter pals did just that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else